und jetzt das heute journal
mit keiner silbe richter und christian
sievers guten abend wir sind mittendrin
in der schwersten phase dieser pandemie
so vieles klar
viel mehr aber nicht ausgerechnet jetzt
da die zahl der an oder mit dem virus
gestorbenen so hoch ist wie nie zuvor
ausgerechnet jetzt da dieses land seit
über zwei monaten mehr oder weniger
harten shutdown leben muss und die
politik entscheiden ob sie den
verlängert verschärft ausgerechnet jetzt
sind viel zu viele fragen ungeklärt was
genau haben die einschränkungen bewirkt
woran liegt es dass die zahlen nicht
deutlich sinken
wer steckt da wen an wie weit sind die
mutierten varianten des virus bereits
verbreitet und wie aussagekräftig ist
die zahlenbasis überhaupt ein land im
blindflug deutschlands amtliche virus
forscher haben heute einiges zu
beantworten
simone friedrich steigende zahlen
wachsende besorgnis immer wieder der
schon verzweifelten appell kontakte
reduzieren abstand halten mund nasen
schutz tragen die korona viren auch die
varianten verbreiten sich so das
robert-koch-institut in allen
bevölkerungs und altersgruppen
die lage könnte sich weiter
verschlimmern in großbritannien hat sich
eine dieser ansteckenden varianten sehr
rasch ausgebreitet
wir können noch nicht abschätzen wie
sich die varianten wie die oft die
situation in deutschland auswirken aber
hier könnten sich auch hier durchsetzen
und zu noch mehr fällen in noch kürzerer
zeit führen nun auch der verstärkte
appell an unternehmen und beschäftigte
home office ist das gebot der stunde
eine studie der hans-böckler-stiftung
nämlich besagt die zahl derjenigen die
im home office arbeiten ist seit dem
ersten shut down im frühjahr gesunken
arbeiten sie von zu hause von immer das
möglich ist
man kann nicht jede aufgabe zu hause
erledigen das ist klar aber ich sehe
unter den arbeitgebern viele
verantwortungsvolle vorreiter die karte
mit den infektionszahlen zeigt fast ganz
deutschland ist alarmierend rot
eingefärbt die sieben tage incidents ist
in vielen landkreisen geradezu
explodiert
saalfeld rudolstadt in thüringen mit der
höchsten zahl über 600 sächsische
schweiz osterzgebirge in sachsen etwas
über 490 hildburghausen in thüringen
etwas unter 490 wohlgemerkt schon ab
einer sieben tage incidents von 200
gelten weitere einschränkungen sie unter
50 zu drücken scheint derzeit
illusorisch sind wird sich noch
schärfere massnahmen nötig oder nur mehr
konsequenz wurde die maske unter dem
kind oder unter der nase hängen hat das
ist natürlich kein schutz und man muss
dazu sagen dass gerade in den kalten
monaten corona während sich besonders
gut vermehren weil sie da sehr stabil
sind lange infektiös bleiben die größten
hoffnungen ruhen also auf den
impfstoffen der chef des
paul-ehrlich-instituts geht sogar so
weit zu sagen wir können glücklich sein
gleich zwei impfstoffe zu haben mit
moderaten nebenwirkungen mit einer sehr
guten wirksamkeit vermutlich auch gegen
die virus mutationen zuversichtlich
positive nachricht moment keine
indikation dass so dass die jetzige
stoffen nicht wirken wenn nicht konnte
relativ schnell umstellen innerhalb von
sechs wochen könnten die impfstoffe dann
an die mutationen angepasst werden
rund 840.000 menschen sind in
deutschland bisher geimpft ein prozent
der bevölkerung und das auch nur mit der
ersten dosis für die so genannte
herdenimmunität müssen aber mehr als 60
prozent mit beiden dosen geimpft werden
es wird also noch dauern ende dieses
jahres so schätzt das rk ii wird die
pandemie dann unter kontrolle sein
hoffentlich professor ulrike protzer ist
die chef geologe in der technischen uni
und am helmholtz zentrum in münchen frau
professor guten abend den abend am sie
denn das gefühl dass sie aktuell noch
genug wissen über das
infektionsgeschehen in deutschland um es
guten gewissens einordnen zu können
ich glaube ich schon denn so wahnsinnig
viel hat sich ja an den parametern die
wir verwenden nicht geändert die
schwankungen natürlich das sind jetzt
melde ungenauigkeiten dabei das sind ja
die labors waren nicht so gut besetzt
über die feiertage deshalb jetzt hat
ich schon einiges an unsicherheit
reingebracht aber ich glaube schon dass
wir die lage immer noch ganz gut
einschätzen können
melde ungenauigkeiten sagen sie wir
haben jetzt zwei wochen nach dem
jahreswechsel und das
robert-koch-institut kann auch nach
diesen zwei wochen immer noch keine
wirklich aussagekräftigen zahlen über
diese schwierige zeit zwischen
weihnachten und silvester präsentieren
kann denn das sein
das kann schon sein weil natürlich ich
hatte das schon gesagt in sehr
ungleichmäßig viel getestet wird uns
natürlich auch melde verzögerungen gibt
und ich glaube dass wir vermehrt machen
müssen ist einfach auf andere parameter
schauen die dann doch sehr konstant sind
und das sind zum beispiel die aufnahmen
ins krankenhaus aufgrund einer tour mit
19 erkrankung denn da fragt natürlich
die erkrankung nicht nach den feiertagen
und es lässt sich sehr exakt und auch
lokal genau bestimmen das interessant
was sie sagen auf andere parameter
schauen der inzidenz fährt auf den wir
im moment ja alle auch die politik ganz
besonders schaut der schwankt ja auch
deshalb weil natürlich abhängig ist wie
wo wer getestet wird und sich das
unmittelbar auf diesen incidents werther
niederschlägt ihr kollege professor
streek sagt jetzt dieser zielwert von 50
neuinfektionen auf 100000 menschen der
vermittler ein falsches bild das sei
kein wissenschaftlicher grenzwert müssen
wir von dieser fixierung auf die
inzidenz wegkommen in deutschland nein
dieser wert hat uns ja doch gute dienste
getan
das ist natürlich kein wissenschaftlich
basierter wert sondern das einfach nach
praktischen gesichtspunkten ausgewählter
wert und der ist berechnet anhand der
kapazität unserer gesundheitsämter so
viel kapazität haben die dann wirklich
auch die infektionsketten
nachzuverfolgen und man wieder drüber
gehen dann können sie es nicht mehr und
das ist ja das was im moment passiert
insofern glaube ich auch wenn er nicht
wissenschaftlich begründet ist es doch
ein praktikabler wert der sich
eigentlich gut bewährt hat frau
professor wenn wir die frage stellen wo
genau steckten wir uns eigentlich im
moment an wie genau ist dieses virus
unterwegs in deutschland dann kriegt man
sehr sehr viele unterschiedliche
antworten
wie kann die politik auf dieser basis
denn entscheidungen treffen die dann
auch wirklich gezielt sind
oder bleibt am ende auch gerade für die
handelnden politiker eben dann doch nur
die holzhammer methode kann man muss
sich immer wieder klar machen das virus
kann sich nicht selbst bewegen und es
kann sich auch nicht im freien irgendwie
selbst fortbewegen sondern fortpflanzen
es muss von menschen bewegt werden das
heißt wir sind diejenigen die es
spazieren tragen und zum nächsten tragen
und das muss ich habe auch immer wieder
bewusst machen und in dem moment in dem
man es schafft die kontakte zu
reduzieren und auch zu menschen von
denen man eigentlich glaubt die kenne
ich die können es ja gar nicht haben die
können es aber natürlich trotzdem haben
und einfach vielleicht noch nicht
bemerken
und ich glaube wenn wir da uns alle
daran halten dann braucht es auch keine
weiteren lockdown maßnahmen dann würde
es funktionieren die frage ist wie
kriegt man alle dazu jetzt ist es noch
ein thema das wir unbedingt besprechen
müssen das ist die sorge vor mutationen
kommende woche so heißt es heute will
sich jetzt die bundeskanzlerin wieder
mit den ministerpräsidenten der länder
treffen auch in der regierung natürlich
viel sorge vor diesen mutationen des
virus was ist denn mit den mutierten
varianten wissen wir da genug über die
verbreitung die genaue verbreitung in
deutschland um diese mutation wirklich
effektiv bekämpfen zu können
nein ehrlich gesagt nicht weil wir in
deutschland bisher das muss man schon
kritisch sagen zu wenig sequenziert
haben
da waren wir sicherlich ein bisschen
nachlässig auch nach lässiger als andere
länder
das holen wir jetzt gerade auf wir haben
jetzt zum beispiel in münchen an den
beiden universitätskliniken uns gerade
mal die während der letzten ja dass die
vom dezember ab angeschaut und da haben
wir die variante nicht gefunden
also sie scheint zumindest noch nicht so
weit verbreitet zu sein aber das muss
man natürlich schon systematisch in ganz
deutschland sich anschauen und auch
erfassen
frau professor bord sei ich danke ihnen
ganz herzlich für das gespräch heute
abend hier haben heute schon mal
unser nächstes thema und doch irgendwie
passt das natürlich zum thema davor in
china hat heute eine vermittlungsmission
begonnen an der die ganze welt größtes
interesse hat die ganze welt mit
ausnahme von chinas machthabern und
deshalb ist ausgesprochen fraglich ob
diese mission erfolg haben kann
allein das ist bereits ein skandal ein
jahr nach ausbruch der korona pandemie
dürfte jetzt endlich ein internationales
forscherteam in wo hahn landen und muss
erstmal für 14 tage in quarantäne der
whu mission vorausgegangen war ein
monatelanges diplomatisches gezerre
johann die stadt die mittlerweile die
ganze welt kennt wo das virus zuerst
festgestellt wurde
im südwesten chinas wo es wie die
internationale fachwelt vermutet auf den
menschen übergesprungen ist
chinas behörden hatten laborproben
vernichtet ärzte eingeschüchtert und
versuchen jetzt mit ihrem gewaltigen
zensur und propaganda apparat den
eigenen bürgern und der welt weiß zu
machen corona komme gar nicht aus china
und roller ist unser korrespondent für
china und jetzt live zu uns geschaltet
aus peking guten abend wulff ein erstes
team der whu durfte gar nicht nach plan
wie unabhängig werden denn die forscher
jetzt ermitteln können
als ich glaube es ist nicht sehr unfair
man braucht nicht viel fantasie um zu
sagen dass der aufklärungswille der
chinesischen regierung doch eher unter
entwickeltes china wird sich nicht
selbst auf die anklagebank setzen
deswegen hat man angst vor diesem
forschungsteam der wm deswegen hat es so
lange gedauert bis dieser reise möglich
war
trotzdem glauben die forscher von der
vero das haben sie vorher auch vor der
reise gesagt dass diese reise sinnvoll
ist dass sie vielleicht doch ein paar
kenntnisse bekommen woher das virus
kommt und wie es ausgebrochen ist aber
eins ist ganz klar es ist eine heikle
mission
china will der welt eine andere
geschichte zählen china will der welt
erzählen dass sie quasi der sieger
dieses weltweiten pandemie kampfes sind
dass sie das virus im griff haben dass
die wirtschaft floriert dass ihr system
eben überlegen ist gegenüber dem westen
in der bekämpfung des
virus unter stört natürlich diese
kommission war es vielleicht salz in die
wunde oder salz in dieses bild einstreut
was eben vielleicht nicht so großartig
ist wie china erzählt eine mission die
enorm politisch aufgeladen ist natürlich
lässt sich denn sagen ob da am ende dann
ein klares ergebnis herauskommen kann
das ist natürlich schwer zu sagen die
mission fängt jetzt erst an die forscher
sind 14 tage in quarantäne
aber selbst am die forscher haben vor
dem beginn der reise sehr deutlich
gemacht dass man die erwartungen nicht
zu hoch hängen soll
wie gesagt man wird erst mal sehen was
sie sehen dürfen in wohin wo sie den
markt besuchen werden und ob sie
wirklich großartiger kenntnis bekommen
die wehr auf versucht bei dieser sehr
aufgeladenen politischen situation
einigermaßen neutral zu bleiben und sie
sagt es wird monate dauern bis erste
ergebnisse gibt und wahrscheinlich gibt
es dann auch über diese ergebnisse
streit
herzlichen dank nach china und jetzt
wirklich ein ganz anderes thema beim
größten sportverband der welt brennt es
und das mal nicht wegen der sportlichen
lage hinter den kulissen läuft einen
machtkampf zwischen dem ehrenamtlichen
chef und dem hauptamtlichen zwischen dfb
präsident und dfb generalsekretär
der machtkampf scheint selbst für die fw
verhältnisse beispiellos und er treibt
jetzt auf einen showdown bei dem nicht
klar ist wer als sieger vom platz geht
immer wahrscheinlicher wird dagegen dass
sich der fußball bund in kürze zumindest
eine neue führungskraft suchen muss und
dann gerät der verband obendrein auch
wieder ins visier der staatsanwälte
markus harm mit mehr
es ist eine veritable krise in der der
dfb steckt vor allem weil die nummer
eins nicht mehr mit der nummer zwei
zusammenarbeiten will präsident keller
mit generalsekretär kurzschluss in einem
schreiben hat keller für morgen zu einer
außerordentlichen präsidiumssitzung
geladen und auch mitgeteilt ich werde
vollumfänglich die informationen
bereitstellen die mir vorliegen und die
mich dazu gebracht haben kein vertrauen
in die zusammenarbeit mit friedrich co
ceos mehr zu haben
was genau keller co ceos vorwirft dazu
will sich keiner aus dem verband außer
vielleicht aber wusste der präsident
schon von einem neuen
ermittlungsverfahren dass die
frankfurter staatsanwaltschaft erneut
gegen den dfb ermittelt bestätigt
staatsanwältin anna krause applus dem
zdf heute schriftlich
es gibt ein neues ermittlungsverfahren
wegen des verdachts der abgabe
unrichtige steuererklärungen und
steueranmeldungen wegen erhalten der
sachzuwendungen beim dfb sind primär der
generalsekretär kurt jooss und der
schatzmeister stefan osnabrück für
steuern verantwortlich im neuen
verfahren soll es um falsche angaben bei
der lohnsteuer sowie in gewerbesteuer
erklärungen von 2015 bis 2020 gehen
der dfb hatte nur ein paar tage nach
einer großangelegten steuerrad sie haben
oktober und dem bekanntwerden des ersten
ermittlungsverfahrens rund 3,3 millionen
euro an die finanzkasse überwiesen wohl
auch aus angst vor neuen durchsuchungen
eine selbstanzeige konnte die
staatsanwaltschaft nicht bestätigen seit
besagt der razzia aber wird unter
anderem gegen cottbus und osnabrück
ermittelt die ermittlungen gegen doktor
kurzes und dr osnabrücker sind
eingeleitet worden weil beweismittel
vorliegen die belegen dass beide als
gesetzliche vertreter des dfv und wegen
ihrer funktionen mit den steuerlichen
themen des verbandes zu tun haben dem
verband droht die aberkennung der
gemeinnützigkeit für den in frage
stehenden zeitraum das könnte
nachzahlungen in millionenhöhe bedeuten
der dfb lässt fragen heute unbeantwortet
doch damit nicht genug nach zdf
informationen hat die dfl die deutsche
fußball liga kurz los heute das
vertrauen entzogen ihn nach einstimmigen
präsidiumsbeschluss von allen sitzungen
ausgeschlossen das geht aus einem brief
der dfl hervor der dem zdf vorliegt
dabei soll es um die weitergabe von
interna gehen reichlich zündstoff im
deutschen fußball-bund das image des
verbandes leidet weiter so jetzt die
ganz konkreten auswirkungen einer
pandemie auf das zentrale element der
demokratie damit beginnen die
nachrichten und kaiser ja eigentlich
sollte der 25 april in thüringen ein
wahltag seien dort steht ja die
vorgezogene landtagswahl an
doch wegen der korona pandemie wird der
termin auf den 26 september verschoben
darauf hat sich das regierungslager aus
linken spd und grünen mit der cdu
geeinigt
damit wird das neue parlament in erfurt
parallel zum bundestag gewählt die vier
parteien hatten sich auf einen
stabilitätspakt geeinigt unter der
bedingung dass es 2021 neuwahlen gibt
hintergrund war der eklat bei der wahl
des fdp-politikers kemmerich zum
ministerpräsidenten mit den stimmen der
afd
wegen der pandemie können eltern dieses
jahr doppelt so viele kinder kranken
tage in anspruch nehmen
das hat der bundestag beschlossen damit
kann jeder elternteil pro kind statt
zehn nur 20 tage beantragen
alleinerziehende maximal 40 genehmigt
werden sie auch dann wenn das kind
gesund ist aber zu hause betreut werden
muss dafür braucht es eine entsprechende
bescheinigung von kita oder schule die
altersgrenze liegt bei zwölf jahren in
frankreich haben sich die
infektionszahlen zuletzt stabilisiert
trotzdem verschärft das land nochmals
seine corona maßnahmen ab samstag gilt
die ausgangssperre landesweit bereits ab
18 uhr um diese uhrzeit müssen auch alle
geschäfte schließen
außerdem werden die grenzkontrollen
verstärkt aus sorge vor der britischen
virus mutationen sie ist in mehreren
französischen städten aufgetaucht unter
anderem
marseille in washington rüsten sich die
sicherheitskräfte weiter für den tag der
amtsübergabe
sie erwarten tausende anhänger des
scheidenden us-präsidenten und massive
ausschreitungen in einer videobotschaft
forderte trump die bürger auf friedlich
zu bleiben
außerdem verurteilte er die gewalt bei
der stürmung des kapitols vergangene
woche seine gegner werfen ihm vor genau
dazu angestachelt zu haben deshalb
stimmte das repräsentantenhaus gestern
abend für ein zweites
amtsenthebungsverfahren im februar
letzten jahres gab es ein urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts das eine
enorme wirkung hat bis heute und weit in
die zukunft hinein
die höchsten richter attestierten jedem
bürger ein recht auf selbstbestimmtes
sterben
das auch dritten erlaube beim suizid zu
helfen
damals hatten die kirchen getobt kein
mensch habe das recht leben zu beenden
jetzt allerdings wagen sich evangelische
theologen vor und stoßen eine debatte an
die es in sich hat welche rolle können
die kirche spielen bei der assistierten
sterbehilfe ist es denkbar dass etwa in
kirchlichen pflegeheimen möglichkeiten
eines assistierten suizids angeboten
werden oder zumindest zugelassen oder
begleitet das wäre ein tabubruch
das ist ein hochsensibles thema ohne
frage die spitzen von evangelischer und
katholischer kirche haben klar gesagt
nicht mit uns aber die diskussion ist
jetzt da und sie bleibt in der welt
ulrike rödler wie frei dürfen wir seien
beim sterben in diesem hospiz in
darmstadt sind sie vorbereitet auf
fragen wie diese zwölf menschen sind
hier derzeit untergebracht das team
nennt sie gäste
sie sind hier um auf den tod zu warten
begleitet von pflegerinnen die trost und
nähe geben und die oft genug auch angst
und verzweiflung nehmen müssen
es gibt verzweifelte aufschrei ich halte
es nicht mehr aus und dann gehen wir ins
gespräch was halten sie nicht mehr aus
sind die schmerzen sind sie aus dieser
situation
manchmal ist es das eingesperrtsein ja
also das gefühl jetzt bin ich hier ich
muss ich warten bis endlich das leben
mal zu ende ist in einem gastbeitrag der
diese woche in der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung erschien haben
führen der evangelische theologen nun
vorgeschlagen assistierte sterbehilfe in
kirchlich diakonischen einrichtungen
zuzulassen
mit ärztlicher hilfe umso zitat
abgesicherte möglichkeiten eines
assistierten suizid in den eigenen
häusern anzubieten
ein brisanter text eine provokation
sagen manche auf jeden fall aber ein
tabubruch aus kirchlicher sicht heißt es
doch im alten testament du sollst nicht
töten
einer der verfasser dieses textes ist
ulrich lilie chef der diakonie
deutschland und früher selbst pfarrer
vor jahren hat er ein evangelisches
hospiz in deutschland gegründet seinen
vorschlag sieht er auch als eine antwort
auf das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts vom februar
das gericht hatte damals das verbot
assistierter sterbehilfe gekippt und die
selbstbestimmung des menschen als hohes
gut anerkannt das sieht ulrich lilie
ähnlich ich möchte nicht dass der suizid
zum normalfall wird ich möchte auch
keinen dammbruch
ich möchte dass wir in besonderen
situationen die selbstbestimmung der
menschen die in diesen situationen dann
am lebensende sich befinden sichern
helfen
matthias pfister ist seit 20 jahren in
der palliativmedizin und im
elisabethenstift auch für das hospiz
zuständig er wild denen die den tod vor
augen haben helfen so gut es geht und so
wenig leidvoll wie möglich von dem
vorschlag der assistierten sterbehilfe
hält er nichts
arzt sein definierter für sich anders
wenn es ihnen schlecht geht dann sind
wir bereit sie zu begleiten aber ich
kann ihnen nicht die zusage geben sie
auf verlangen jetzt ins all zu befördern
dass das schaffe ich persönlich nicht
gleichwohl das urteil aus karlsruhe ist
in der welt und es hat den rahmen der
diskussion zum thema sterbehilfe in
deutschland gesprengt es wird sie geben
hierzulande aber in diakonischen
einrichtungen der vorsitzende der
evangelischen kirche hält den vorschlag
nicht für tragbar die situation um die
es geht sind zu kompliziert als dass man
sich da einfach machen könnte aber ich
entnehme dem fünften gebot du sollst
dich töten schon einen klaren auftrag
sich für den schutz des lebens
einzusetzen und deswegen sollten wir uns
nicht an der organisierten hilfe zum
suizid beteiligen
dennoch die diskussion um sterbehilfe
ist nicht mehr aufzuhalten
geführt wird sie allerdings derzeit in
einem nahezu rechtsfreien raum denn die
bundesregierung hat nach dem karlsruher
urteil noch kein gesetz geschaffen
derweil fallen in der praxis
entscheidungen in den krankenhäusern
jeden tag in der grauzone schwieriges
thema über das wir alle nachdenken
müssen
und hier macht jetzt kaiser weiter mit
meldungen zur wirtschaft wie sehr die
korona pandemie auf die konjunktur
drücken würde dazu hatte es in den
vergangenen monaten die
unterschiedlichsten prognosen gegeben
nun werden die schätzungen immer wieder
laut dem statistischen bundesamt sank
das bruttoinlandsprodukt 2020 um fünf
prozent gab und gibt es denn noch
lichtblicke frank bethmann in frankfurt
ja beispielsweise am bau war von corona
nicht viel zu spüren ebenso bunte der
online-handel und florierte das geschäft
mit lebensmitteln
auch gesamtwirtschaftlich bleibt es
dabei 2020 möchte man schnell vergessen
die wirtschaftliche bilanz eines
krisenjahres
die exporte brechen um fast zehn prozent
ein wenig besser die importe der private
konsum geht um sechs prozent zurück und
erstmalig nach 14 jahren sind wieder
weniger menschen in lohn und brot dem
kurzarbeitergeld sei dank fällt das
minus moderat aus die bundesregierung
nimmt auch sonst viel geld in die hand
um schlimmeres zu verhindern der preis
ist hoch das finanzdefizit des bundes
ist das zweithöchste seit der
wiedervereinigung
immerhin der vergleich mit unseren
europäischen nachbarn zeigt deutschland
kommt mit einem minus von fünf prozent
zum vorjahr noch vergleichsweise
glimpflich davon in frankreich italien
und vor allem spanien durch die
konjunktur 2020 deutlich stärker ein
neben den vielen rettungspaketen hilft
dass deutschland sehr industrie lastig
ist gerade jetzt profitiert das
verarbeitende gewerbe davon dass trotz
shutdowns weiter produziert und wieder
exportiert werden kann
20 21 wird besser doch längst nicht
wieder gut
es wird damit gerechnet dass zahlreiche
betriebe ausgezehrt durch die pandemie
insolvenz anmelden müssen
dann kann die börse frank mit
spektakulären zaubershows wurde
siegfried fischbacher berühmt als teil
des magier duo siegfried und roy
nun ist er im alter von 81 jahren
gestorben
die auftritte mit weißen löwen und
tigern waren legendär
ein mix aus illusion und zirkus mit dem
die gebürtigen deutschen las vegas
eroberten
2003 wurde roy von einem tiger schwer
verletzt daraufhin zogen sich die
entertainer aus dem geschäft zurück mai
starb im vergangenen jahr an den folgen
einer corona infektion weg nun an einer
krebserkrankung
das hier war über generationen hinweg
eine verlässliche instanz im bücherregal
eine institution der brockhaus in 30
bänden
daraus ist jetzt auch schon 15 jahre her
dass davon die allerletzte auflage
erschienen ist
fünf jahre zuvor exakt am morgigen tag
vor 20 jahren war im netz ein lexikon
der anderen art gestartet das seitdem
aus unserem leben nicht mehr wegzudenken
ist ein echtes erfolgsmodell wikipedia
ein vergleich nur würde man nur die
deutschen wikipedia einträge als reinen
text drucken dann wäre das eine sammlung
von fast 1.500 stattlichen lexikon
bänden mit über 2,5 millionen artikeln
20 jahre wikipedia was das neue standard
nachschlagewerk mit uns macht und wie
zuverlässig es ist zeigt stefan tigges
es war kurz nachdem die internetblase
geplatzt war 2001 so sahen damals handys
aus facebook gab es nicht twitter gab es
auch nicht da gründete der
internet-unternehmer jimmy wales
zusammen mit einem kollegen wikipedia
das ziel simpel das wissen der welt
allen menschen zugänglich machen
ich bin ein pathologischer optimist
deshalb dachte ich sehr früh das könnte
eine große idee sein und schon im ersten
jahr haben wir rasantes wachstum erlebt
die community wuchs und orte etwas
faszinierendes auf da wusste ich das
wird was jeder kann mitschreiben es gibt
keine zentrale steuerung was wikipedia
groß gemacht hat sorgte auch immer
wieder für kritik kann das stimmen was
da steht vor zwölf jahren behauptete zum
beispiel ein nutzer die karl-marx-allee
würde von berlinern stalins badezimmer
genannt wegen der charakteristischen
keramikfliesen die falschbehauptung
blieb zwei jahre stehen bis sie
korrigiert wurde
mittlerweile haben die ehrenamtlichen
wikipedianer kontrollmechanismen
eingezogen die so etwas verhindern
sollen
als beispielsweise im dezember eine
bundestagsabgeordnete versuchte ihre
politische agenda im artikel über sich
unterzubringen waren ihre änderungen
wenige minuten später wieder gelöscht
der erste schritt ist auf jeden fall die
sogenannte eingangskontrolle das sind
ehrenamtliche wikipedianer deren beitrag
zur wikipedia darin besteht jede
änderung in der enzyklopädie anzuschauen
dadurch wird zum beispiel verhindert
dass ganz offensichtlicher unsinn in die
artikel reinkommt trotz einiger fehler
es sind fakten die zählen die wikipedia
stemmt sich damit auch gegen
entwicklungen der letzten jahre in denen
desinformation und lügen massenhaft im
netz verbreitet wurden also angesichts
von fake news und von miss informationen
auf sozialen plattformen gilt jetzt
gerade wikipedia und die qualität
sicherungsmechanismen die auf dieser
plattform etabliert wurden als garant
einer oder als hilfe und
sicherheitsmechanismen um für gutes
wissen zu stehen
wikipedia ist über die jahre zu einer
digitalen wissens institution gewachsen
keine schlechte bilanz für eine 20 jahre
alte idee so ich hab jetzt hört man bei
wikipedia hier nachgeguckt und zwar
unter dem stichwort maybrit illner mit
einem tee steht maybrit illner ist eine
politische talkshow im zdf
das stimmt das thema heute steht nicht
im computer das habe ich für sie
langsames impfen schnelles virus droht
der lange winter shot down das ist die
frage antworten gleich bei maybrit
illner und wir zwei freuen uns auch
morgen wieder auf sie und empfehlen
ihnen noch das heute-journal update um
kurz nach halb eins mit nazan guckte mir
[Musik]
meine damen und herren wenn sie langsam
von neuschnee die nase voll haben dann
habe ich was für sie denn die tiefs hier
erhan und flavio die lassen morgen weil
ein bisschen platz für die hochs bogena
und jana und das -hoch cerna das zieht
in richtung hoch buch china und das
bedeutet wir bekommen da eine kleine
hochdruckbrücke und damit beruhigt sich
das wetter für naja sagen wir mal so 24
bis 36 stunden
heute nacht aber fällt noch schnee und
das hängt zusammen mit diesem tief
besonders hier zwischen dem saarland und
dem alpenrand und auch über den
nordosten deutschland ziehen in der
nacht noch einige schneeschauer hinweg
an der donau bildet sich auch mal nebel
sonst aber bleibt die nacht trocken
es ist aber überall kalt genug für
glätte machen sie sich also nach wie vor
auf winterliche straßenverhältnisse
gefasst bei tiefsttemperaturen meist im
leichten bis mäßigen frost in bayern
geht sogar in den strengen frost von
minus acht bis minus zehn grad
die temperaturen morgen liegen zwischen
minus fünf grad an den alpen und maximal
3 grad am niederrhein und morgen fällt
kaum noch schnee vielleicht noch am
nordrand des erzgebirges auch im
thüringer wald oder im südlichen
brandenburg und einige schneeschauer
gibt es vielleicht auch noch im
schwarzwald sonst wechseln sonne und
wolken freundlich miteinander ab und
noch etwas freundlicher wird dann der
samstag bei temperaturen von minus sechs
bis plus 2 grad aber am sonntag da
kommen dann von best neue schnee und
schneeregen wollten heran
dann wird es wieder sehr gefährlich
glatt auf den straßen die neue woche
startet erst nochmal recht kühl bei
minus zwei bis plus fünf grad war
spätestens mitte der woche gibt es dann
tauwetter
schönen abend noch